we are truly this close kelly ripa is
totally inspired by her 19 year old
daughter lola
i'm the luckiest woman in america the
live with kelly and ryan co-host covers
the latest issue of people magazine with
her hubby mark consuelos
and their three kiddos 23 year old
michael
lola and 17 year old joaquin and
inside the mag kelly reveals her
daughter has taught her so much about
being
a modern day woman quote it really gives
me hope her generation really supports
each other the way she and her friends
have each other's backs
for all the talk about women helping
other women i
see it in her generation in a way i
never have before
i think what they have learned so far in
their young lives
is that you show up for people when they
show up for you
as for what lola's learned from her
rents the teen said her dad taught her
to take
everything day by day not to dwell on
the past
but to focus on the future and mark
he says he hasn't had to be an
overbearing dad she's so
spectacular and i hate three people and
i haven't met them those are her first
boyfriends i haven't met them yet but i
know i hate them as overprotective as i
thought i would be when she was born and
i was holding her in my arms
i've mellowed a bit because i'm really
aware of what a good head on her
shoulders she has
she's such a great girl she's you know
she makes good choices
kelly notes that she and mark have more
wisdom and
fewer nerves as their kids grow up
michael graduated from nyu this spring
now lola is attending the same
university and when eti caught up with a
couple last year
right after their baby girl graduated
from high school
they opened up about only having one
bird left in the nest
you two are closer to an empty nest
we are truly
and kelly revealed how she plans on
celebrating when 17 year old joaquin
flies the coop i'm truly going to be
running through the house naked
i just want everybody to know that i'm
going to be sitting on every piece of
furniture naked
be warned before you come over that's
what i'll be doing in my spare time
that's amazing
and you're welcome america as you should
you deserve it honey
you